we've been very clear
that there is an increase that there are
more children coming across the border
than we have facilities for at this
point in time
well the biden administration admitting
there isn't enough space for all those
kids at the borders
as authorities reportedly have
encountered more than a hundred thousand
migrants
in the last four weeks but still they
won't call it a crisis
do you believe that right now there's a
crisis at the border the answer is no
i think there is a challenge at the
border that we are managing
[Applause]
look i don't think we need to sit here
and put new labels on what we have
already conveyed is challenging
let's go you guys come on come on let's
go
they just don't want to say it is a
crisis it's a crisis
and i got a feeling the guy right there
screen right fox news contributor and
retired acting ice director tom homan
agrees
uh you know they're in a pickle because
uh joe biden during the campaign made it
very clear
if i'm elected essentially we're going
to have open borders going to make it
easier for you to come into the country
and now they've got a messaging problem
they say don't come
but the people down south are not
getting the message tom
well look they should be embarrassed
right you know american people can do
math
the apprehension is over a hundred
thousand that's triple well it was a
year ago
under trump policies and you know
actions speak louder than words they can
say hey i want to say
but when you release thousands of people
into united states someone even coded
and you you don't want to detain them
they send a clear message to the world
so their action speaks much longer
much louder than what the words are
attempting to use but
you know there's two things they're
ignoring they're ignoring two things
number one they're ignoring that
based on doj's data department justice
data ninety percent of central americans
who claim asylum at the border never get
relief because they either don't show up
or they don't qualify
the other data marked or missing is
their own dhs life cycle report that
says less than three percent
of the hundreds of thousands of families
that were ordered deported
by an immigration judge refused to leave
three percent
left 97 stayed and what's the penalty
they're going to get amnesty on their
biden plan
well you know over the last 72 hours i
have heard so many people in the
administration
who will not call it a crisis have said
you know what we inherited
a broken system when you look at the
numbers
it seems like the old system under
donald trump
actually worked at keeping people out of
the country until they're processed
legally
they inherited the most secure border
i've seen in my third almost 35-year
career
so they're lying to the american people
and the promises they made look
it doesn't take a genius to realize when
you make promises that hey we're going
to have amnesty we're going to fix
doctor we'll give you free health care
we're going they already they already
crippled ice 90
their authorities taken away because
there's no interior enforcement they're
being released as quickly as possible
from the border again
in 1415 we built detention centers we
built 3 000 family beds we built adult
facilities
we held people and after they lost their
case ice removed them
and that's what happened the surge went
down because we ended the enticements
they're doing the complete
opposite now not by accident not by
incompetence but by design
this is an open borders agenda and
they're not hiding it very well
during the month of february uh
deportations
and arrests according to figures
compiled by the washington post
they both fell by 60 percent so if you
if you're talking about a hundred
thousand people
that's 60 000 people that they did not
deport
and they did not arrest and there's a a
u.s district judge down there dr
uh judge drew tipton who said
that uh he noticed with his caseload
changing
he said uh ice used to automatically
deport felons arrested in texas for
human smuggling
now they're released into the united
states he would sentence somebody
to be deported that then ice would just
drop them
on the street in texas instead of
sending them back to mexico
that is what has happened in the last
month or two
look the bottom line is ninety percent
of the criminal aliens i saw
and removed last year cannot be arrested
and removed this year
90 percent of the criminals that they
arrested and removed last year are no
longer on the table because of new
priorities of administration
look this is the first president in the
nation's history
that's facilitating illegal immigration
on our southern border there's no other
word for it when you say
you can come to the united states we're
not going to detain you we're going to
reach as quick as possible
ice we're taking 90 percent of your
authority away we're going to give
amnesty we're going to reward those who
who
who committed a crime on the border i
mean this this is just
this again this isn't incompetency this
is by design this is an open borders
agenda they've sold out to the
progressive
and and we're we're going to lose the
border you think the numbers are bad now
wait till they end title 42 then you're
going to see a surge that we've never
seen before
tom you have been a public servant for
decades
and you've worked for president obama
president trump
president trump's system is being taken
apart piece by piece
have you talked to president trump since
he left office
and has observed what's happening in our
southern border and and
if so how did he describe it
he described as almost exactly as
sustainable just have talked to him
he he's he's shocked at how how
how this new administration is is is
selling out our country look
we have a right to have a sovereign
nation we have a right to have a secured
border
and president trump recognized that like
i said before president trump recognized
that 90
of these people don't win their case
when they get here and they don't leave
and he recognized that that's why the
remaining mexico program was one of the
greatest things he
he did because make him wait in mexico
and and make their claim and and and if
you're really escaping fear and
persecution from your homeland
and you cross through two or three
different countries where you escape
that persecution from your home
government
is it really about fear and persecution
or is it about getting to the united
states
where now you can get a job illegally
because the mind administration tells
ice you can't do works
enforcement operations anymore i think
president trump is is concerned about
this country he made that clear to me
and i think he's going to stay in the
fight along
and i'm gonna stay in a fight too i mean
i'm not gonna shut up they're not gonna
shut me up because
i i've worked for six different
presidents i know all this stuff works
and this is what they're doing right now
is by design
our our border is at chaos and uh the
men and women the borba tories are
better and the president has abandoned
them
well i have heard that there's a lot of
frustration with uh
immigration and dhs so let's see what
happens uh tom homan former acting ice
director sir thank you very much for
joining us today